welcome to another edition of beginner
breakdown today I had the pleasure of
playing a beginner in three games so
we're going to see what the beginner did
right see what he did wrong and also see
what I did right see what I did wrong in
the first match I had the white pieces
so it starts out pretty standard
efore the King's pawn opening black
counters 'if I've pretty standard for
beginners the double King pawn opening
so white brings out his knight to f3 and
black plays Knight to f6 this is called
the petrov defense it's pretty good if
black can play it correctly so after
Knight takes pawn an idea might be he
took one of my pawns I better capture
upon back Knight to f6 Knight to Knight
the knight on f6 takes the pawn on e4
now this falls for a very simple trap
that a lot of people have seen before so
white brings out his Queen on - E - just
efile is now the action file well both
Kings are on it
the Queen's and two knights so now if
this Knight moves he'll be in trouble so
he tries to defend the knight with d5 we
then attack the knight forcing it off
the e-file and now at home what should
white play to crush black you got a Jim
what would Knight to c6 now the king is
in check a discovered check and his
Queens attacked so if he tries to move
his Queen will just take it a lot of
people say well what about knight Knight
takes
I get a pawn I'm doing great well true
the king is in check and true or Knight
is attacking the Queen but look at what
the King can do to get out of it
king takes f7 okay so we want to watch
out for that okay but amazingly my
opponent did not play into this
variation he plays the correct move d6
attacks the night
now if I move my knight back which I do
and now if he captures and now I play
Queen to e2 what move can he play to
save his night forever and not so if he
tries the move d5 again why does that
lose do you know you know what white
would play to win this Knight just
attack it right so this Knight is in a
pin so we want to attack thin pieces so
we're going to play d3 and now there's
no way this Knight can move so he's dead
alright so so what move can black make
to save his knight in this position
d5 won't work f5 and Bishop the f5 fall
to the same same issues right we'll just
play d3 and win it do you know Suzie
knew a Queen to e7 okay so now if we
play d3 he'll be like okay I'm safe and
nothing gained nothing lost but in the
game it goes d6 I retreat back to f3 and
black unfortunate ake the pond we need
to take the pawn he plays Knight to c6
to develop the the piece
so now we protect the pile with Knight
to c3 Bishop comes out to attack the
knight to pin the Queen but we can just
play Bishop to e2 and break the pin
black plays a6 so in this position if
you're playing black at home yeah you're
sure you're down upon but all is not
lost you probably want to get your
pieces off the back row and then get
castle okay a six doesn't really fall
into any of that stuff so now we can
play d4 and now we got our pawns all
nice so when black plays d5 push and
unfortunately at this point black makes
a fortune mistake so when when your pawn
is it well when you're being attacked so
you see your knight is under attack here
a simple thing to do is okay he's
attacking my knight let's move the
knight okay we don't need to try to do
anything crazy here
and unfortunately the craziness doesn't
get too good right and Bishop the e7
protects the knight but here was under
attack so we probably wanted to move it
so pawn takes f6
and we'll take the knight now but
unfortunately we take this pawn
threatening pawn takes the Queen so
Queen takes it putting the bishop in a
pin so now White's our way we'll have
the double pawns but it is okay because
he's got a great material advantage so
that's all right so Queen to d6 so now
we can attack it he does not take it
does not take it yeah he retreats his
eye Queen to d7 Queen takes
so there's actually a pretty cool way to
protect this rook castle okay now you're
at least you're safe and and you'll get
the play on for at least another ten
moves unfortunately by playing rook to
f8
it's all over all right it's just too
much it's going on and you're never
going to survive this okay so so that's
that's the end of a game one okay so so
let's look at where he made his downfall
all right so the opening so far so good
but he doesn't take back the pawn it's
always good because now I'll have a
center pond there forever so brings out
the bishop there and not a six okay
he didn't try to get castled he played a
six and can't be raised in time in the
opening okay not new game alright so but
you know so he lost Game 1 of our series
all right no big deal there's always
game - ok and game - he plays a better
or maybe I play worse I don't know we'll
have to see you be the judge all right
all right so so I have black in this
game I so white plays d4 black plays d5
Knight f3 knight c6 I usually don't play
e5 but I thought just for illustrative
purposes and get my opponent chance I
play it so he plays Knight to c3 which
is kind of slow right I mean you want to
get your bishop you [ __ ] about either
to c4 or b5 attacking the knight all
right Knight to c3
I protect the pawn but it doesn't get
you any step closer to castling and it's
just not not the best not the best so
Knight to f6
so now Bishop the b5 attacks the night
so I see a lot of people freaked out
when they get this Knight attack like oh
my god let's pin my knight
it's like don't do that don't do that or
I gotta attack you you're so annoying
it's like if you
he wants to take it it's just going to
happen okay so you don't need to really
do anything about that all right so just
I want to get my pieces develop and
castled so let's just stick with that
plan
so Bishop the c5 and now he plays a3 so
you didn't do anything to stop me from
castling so I Castle
so now white plays rook the b1 this plan
is probably not advisable he could play
b4 anyway right now if you really want
to play before you he doesn't have to
double prepare it okay a3 was sufficient
enough he should be getting castled and
safe so so route the b1 so now so now I
should probably try to get my bishop in
the game by playing either d6 because
it's not a pin anymore but instead I do
end up playing Knight up here which is
not the best so Knight to d5 or nay a
knight to d4 and so now he plays the
move B for so I retreat alright so you
know it's pretty simple if your piece is
getting a pact don't try to do anything
crazy you can just retreat right all
right so now he plays Bishop to c4
getting his Bishop on this a nice
diagonal here so now I take all right
and he takes all right so so why did I
do that am I the worst chess player of
all time I've just given pieces four
pawns
don't answer that at home please all
right so so there's a fork there's a two
pieces a file apart on the same rank
boom pawn fork d5 okay so now he's like
alright I'm at least going to get a pawn
for it which is good
yes he could have done something crazier
yes oh yes in this position I I thought
this was better
so now so now f5 and Bishop to d3 and so
now P for and unfortunately I am NOT
going to win my piece back even though
he is in this fork again white can make
a move greater or equal to this threat
and the threat is way greater so
everybody figure out how we can get out
of this so there's a couple different
ways actually he could just take the
knight or better he could check all
right always good to check so the King
moves over and now he can move the
knight to safety Knight to e5 now he's
threatening Knight to f7 check even
though I'm playing a beginner I decided
I'm going to play four tricks alright
he's just doing too good alright so
Queen to h4 so I'm hoping that he can't
resist the urge to check me all right
then I would take he would take and so I
sacrifice an exchange what I think I'm
going to get checkmate can everybody see
how I can maybe checkmate him or win his
queen Julian can Knight - si - no no so
so Julian gets it wrong so baby should
be in this class after all
so let's see if the ultimate beginner
can can figure this out
what's the other check this night has so
I can play Knight f3 check and then then
yeah if he just takes with the pawn boom
checkmate and if he takes with the Queen
I'll be doing fine too because I'll just
take so forth
alright so so I break one of my own
rules never play hope just okay
especially when you're so much better
than your opponent right what's the
point so he finds the right move this is
the one move I was hoping he wouldn't
make of course he plays at g3 so now I
have to go back to f6
alright so now he plays f4 and I forget
about the rule on % unbelievable and so
I decide you know this guy's just giving
me too much trouble I'm gonna play
Knight f3 check yeah all right so so he
moves this King to f1 he should have
obviously taken pawn takes Queen takes
and then I think he would be up a pawn
against me
but but I would have this nice check and
yeah I would give me all the
compensation I would need for that one
alright so f4 so Knight f3 check yeah
and so so my opponent never cancelled in
these games and he's lent them letting
me check him so much alright so he needs
to watch out for the and threatening all
these cool check mates and all this so
now I take take and now I'm up the pawn
and crushing alright
uh-oh unfortunately my opponent does not
take back here but let's let's not laugh
at them too much here if you weren't
going to take back here what move could
you play that would be kind of cool here
Bishop the bee to putting the night in a
pin activating your pieces but I mean I
would I would probably just taken back
but but Bishop b2 might actually be the
best move here Bishop b2 is the best
move it's been confirmed so but
unfortunately he doesn't do either of
those he plays the move d3
alright so now I'm like okay my knight I
get mine I free so take take and now
he's threatening to boxing my bishop
here so what do you think I do I move my
bishop okay how hard is it okay so if
they're threatening your piece somehow
to win a piece trying to move that piece
all right so Bishop d4 attack it alright
but unfortunately it's not fainted so
Bishop takes c3 rook to be three attacks
the bishop all right but remember it's
still protected by the Queen so we're
doing okay so Bishop the e6 look get
everybody in the same line all right so
he sees that I'm attacking this pawn so
he should try to protect it I guess
Queen to e2 would probably be the best
okay but instead he plays h3
most likely all right they're saying
after Queen to e2 here queen the d4
might be pretty good but I don't know
and then yeah and then it's all crumbles
it all crumbles down for way but I mean
pretty much everything is good for white
here all right all right excuse me for
black so so h3 so check King f2 now I
got a cool move it's called an
intermezzo
so everybody's expecting me I'll just
take it just take you're so good but I
move my rook my last piece that was just
sitting around into the game and
attacked the Queen so he's got to play
Queen to see to keep the keep the guy
protected and now I play the check King
to g2 Bishop takes so now we decided to
use okay to take back and now you just
push this pawn to victory III King to f3
it's never going to run toward all your
own it's big bad pieces keep the g2 King
to e2 right and I decided I see mate I
don't even want the rook check King take
c3 and how can you put the finishing
touches on this game I give you a hint
this rooks doing a great job this Queens
doing a great job who's the only guy not
doing a great job this guy
Tecton the F pawn all right yeah
so check mate all right so that one he
lasted about 30 moves and he did pretty
good so let's do a quick review see see
exactly where he went wrong because at
one point he might have been doing ok so
e4 e5 Knight f3
so Castle okay so this was a bad idea
rook to be one sure to get castled okay
so at this point he's doing okay here
okay so this is the critical point
he plays f4 which probably wasn't the
best move but I make a mistake here so
Knight to f3 check he needs to just take
pawn takes Queen takes rook check and
then you can just back up as bishop and
he'll be up upon and doing okay but when
he does not take back tonight
that's where he crumbles alright so just
those slightest mistakes add up okay so
this is game 3 of the match alright and
this time I have the white pieces again
so let's see if he can do do all right
here alright so II for black plays not
East 6 it plays a 5 it's debatable so so
now I remember from the last game he
plays Knight f3 I play Knight f6 ok so
we always want to be getting better
alright so I decide I want to trick them
ok I want to go into the fried liver
where my bishops here his knights on f6
and my nights on g5 ok that's what I
want okay so so a good way to try to get
people to play that you know is to play
Bishop to c4 because it's such a natural
move to just play up you play as bishop
there I'll play my Knight to f6 which is
exactly what happens okay so now Knight
f3 I'm one hop away from getting my
dream scenario so now if he plays Knight
to c6 look at what just happened okay so
if you really want to achieve this
position and you're not sure you can get
it with your opponent try playing Bishop
the c-4 in your second move instead of
Knight to f3 you have a trick them
alright alright but he doesn't play
Knight to c6 he plays the move now no
questions at this time you plays Bishop
to b4 this is not a good spot for your
Bishop period it wants to be on c5
attacking the F pawn okay because it's
so easy for me to just attack it but I
don't even want to attack it I want to I
want to get up here alright but I don't
play there obviously because if I do
that he could just castle I want to take
free material Knight takes pawn okay and
so now we get kind of a variation of the
fried liver attack Knight takes f7 now
King takes Queen to f3 check and so now
if he plays King to e6
I will Castle and then I'm going to
check them and it's you can see this is
not very safe for black okay
so unfortunately he makes it even worse
boo than King to e6 he goes back home to
e8 where he thinks he's safe okay and
everybody okay so I have two attackers
of this Knight and you'll get one
defender so now I can take with a queen
and I'm threatening checkmate or I could
take with the bishop and I'm also
threatening checkmate now if you may
find our lectures at home you would know
you've got to take with the bishop
because remember if you're on the attack
don't trade pieces okay who's on the
attack white it so take with the bishop
okay now I'm threatening checkmate
what should black do to get out of this
checkmate Queen to e7 Chuck
and so by fortunately you know he's a
newcomer so I'm going to attack your
bishop and game over okay all right so
now so those were my games against the
beginner okay so not the best not the
worst but now I got to play the champ a
couple moves a couple days ago okay so
so this is a guy that's a little bit uh
wise higher Raider than me but just
because he's higher rated doesn't mean
he's better than me okay bigger than me
but not bad the champ yeah yeah the
champ is Preston he's our resident guy
who who likes to give the grandmasters a
tough time so sometimes they send in the
beginner breakdown coach to set them in
this place okay so here we go so white
starts out d4 I'm white in the three
game match and black plays ePHI okay so
just take it all right I mean how hard
is it all right so black plays Knight to
c6 he wants to get his pawn back so
Knight f3 protects the pawn Queen to e7
now a lot of people might be like oh you
got to play Bishop f4 and just just hold
on try to hold on this pawn forever okay
not a good idea just uh no nope just
just give it back it's like you what you
want it you want it you got it okay it
takes Queen takes and now we'll just
develop normally
okay so c6 Bishop g2 d5 Castle see that
but move eight White's Castle safe black
all his pieces besides his Queen or on
the back row he's got that going for him
whatever that
is which watch this [ __ ] up the f5 now
just break it open see when you are
castled and safe and in your opponent is
it you have to do whatever it takes to
break open the center ok because if you
just like just like you know just goof
around
you know Bishop here or something you
can't make any progress okay so just
break open the center and good things
will happen
pawn takes Knight takes e4 so it's like
oh yeah you just gave me a three-night
all right
Bishop takes e4 Bishop takes okay so so
the same thing is in that Petroff
defense that we saw earlier if black
plays Queen takes bishop here it's not
good because rook goes to e1 and it's a
bad pin okay alright so so he's not
going to take back okay he sees it and
he plays Bishop to d6 not threatening
checkmate okay so so now Bishop the f4
and so now he's math alright so so when
you're mad you're going to do stupid
things
so Queen takes even though he sees it
rook to e1 and it's not going to last
very long here yep now we just just
cause we're up a lot of material we need
to just keep the pedal to the metal
Queen to d2 putting this bishop in a pin
rook the d8 take with the big piece
and uh how can we get the finishing
touches on this anybody rook to d1 loses
a clean this is it yeah yeah you never
want to stop short you got to go all the
way II won check remember checks and
then we just yeah so now we could take
even more of his material but however we
do it all right so like a castle quick
then he broke open the center and he
easily won but let's give up Preston I
guess we'll let him get back into the
match I guess here he got the white
pieces in Game two and he was really mad
so so you never want to play somebody
when they're really mad because they're
going to be playing on emotion and
sometimes that can be good that can be
good and so let me flip the board here
and so Preston starts out efore and I
can't believe I play e5 but I do okay
Knight f3 Knight f6 so I've tried to get
into the patch off the fence because I
know how to play it but Bishop the c4 or
actually he plays a the weak move Knight
to c3 Bishop c5 Bishop to c4 so black
gets castled so I achieve might my
objective pretty quick because I knew
Preston was man wanted to attack me so I
got castle quick but sometimes just
because you're in a castle doesn't mean
they're not going to come and get you
because now press the knows where I'm
going to be for the rest of the game all
right so Knight to c6 Bishop to b3 and I
make a mistake here
I play Knight to d4 okay and that drops
upon okay Knight takes e4 but I got rid
of his a LightSquared bishop but I but
it's probably not worth a full pulling
for that so rook to e8 and white
protects with d4 Bishop to d6 and now
he'll play f4 alright so now look at
where my bishop and Knight are okay and
look at where this e pawn is so so I
should be aware of this but I'm not okay
so I make a rather strange move b5 and
and now he's got a tactic he takes this
pawn and now when I take back he gets
the pawn fork okay that you never really
want to fall for a pawn forked mean it's
pretty elementary and not very good so I
continue with my plan of b4 so he just
moves his Knight Bishop to e7 so pawn
takes Bishop takes and now preston sees
a check Queen to h5 sorry retreat back
to g8 so now what do you think preston
does he's got a pretty good move here
you see it Steven what is it yeah yeah
yeah just look for the checks yeah most
so if anybody can tell me what I was
thinking with my b5 before playing I
really like to know but all it did was
hurt me right all right so you got to
know what you're doing before you just
really nearly up so King f8 so he takes
my rook now I try to block in his a guy
with c6
it gets his night text my Brooke and
it's not going very well
not very going well but I get a check in
so that's a feeling all right now King
to h1 I always check if he came after he
checked me actually went to AJ
so now I can move my work to f/8 and so
now he gets this Bishop off the back row
Queen here and we got it ooh so do I
really miss the move c5 here
all right so so sometimes we got to look
at that computer to make sure everything
is going okay yep so so even though I'm
merely mad that I missed the move c5 the
computer stuff it's no beat up by nine
points though so I don't think I should
really beat myself up for missing that
all right but c5 it kind of breaks that
up the defense of the young the night
here
okay all right but I can get over it all
right I put my King back on g8 I was
very important if you look at all the
games that uh all the guys have won all
of these rooks got in the action all the
players got to play while usually that
the loser is just those pieces are
shifting at home like not plain really
you know so if you can play it with more
pieces than your opponent you're doing
pretty good Bishop to a6 and now how
does preston humiliate me Jim got pay
attention if this get this white has
made to and you wouldn't have any idea
you probably say Oh me and my Queens
lost though me and I I guess I go
through more trigonometry room what we
got well we got white to move made into
I shoulda just be a man my Queen stuck
let's trap just take the rook I'd love
to play you any day of the week just
take the way all right Queens for work
and then what do you have is some kind
of saving grace here then you're alright
the only legal check well that well you
got this kind of checks but but these
are the good checks
checkmate all right game over all right
so so now the series is tied one to one
and we got pivotal Game three the size
of Game three the determine who's the
champion if I can find it though
oh my god League game three at home all
right here it is here's the final game
of the match all right so Preston saw
that his e5 is garbage so we decided not
to play it's d4 d5 c4 Knight f6 Knight
to c3 e six alright blocks in this
Bishop thank you thank you thank you so
so if we're white and we're playing we
never want to take this and let us fish
up free alright we want to keep this
Bishop on c8 a joke piece the whole game
okay so let's see if we can accomplish
that so Bishop the F for Bishop the d6
Bishop g3 we don't really care about
these double pawns okay it's kind of
cool
just take my board all right so black
it's Castle all right so so he's feeling
pretty good here interesting so he gets
castle all right
so Knight to f3 but we'll just develop
like we know I really would pawn takes
c4 all right you never really want to
take on c4 when you're when you're in
the system is black okay because it
allows white to do a very simple thing
efore right now my pawns are all great
and I'm threatening the the devastating
pawn fork here okay
so but but he should see that he's in a
pawn fork or possibly so he takes takes
okay so now my H file is open and I'm
hitting this crucial h7 square okay so
now I can think about trying to get
checkmates up here oh right
alright so so he decides he's going to
try to keep the pawn with b5 so so I
don't even know if that move is good I
mean can I just take it anyway
no but he'll get my e-pawn okay so
that's why you got to think things on
shows okay so
so b5 Queen to c2 so I'm already
envisioning checkmate ideas okay b5
remove the defender all right
easy enough all right so Bishop the b7
I'm all excited now so now I play e5 and
the game is pretty much already over
right b4
so now we can just take right and if he
takes our night checkmate
it takes here so so you see just goes
you're in a castle doesn't mean you're
automatically safe especially you don't
want open lines coming toward your
castle here all right
so so this game is pretty much pretty
much a wash here you can't even take it
back because it's still checkmate
so what's the only legal move well not
legal but what's the only move that
doesn't lose any more material g6 yep
all right Knight to e4 Bishop takes
Queen takes so now I'm threatening the
rook Knight to d7 I bet you everybody in
the audience can shout out what I do
here we just had to guess even though
it's not even that good
yeah Queen h4 trying to threaten
checkmate right so he takes with the
night let's try to threaten checkmate
again okay are all the kind of cool
stuff so Knight to h5 Bishop takes
okay so the reason why let me see
G for so then I make me look bad so yeah
so I really have to play Knight up six
right let's just say oh what if he tries
well then we can just retreat so Knight
f6 and then Knight takes yeah it looks
pretty good so why did I just play g4 is
a good question and I don't have a good
answer for that
alright so cheap for yeah I want to make
him suffer against Adam Bishop takes e4
e5 so now
Preston trying to do like I did in the
first match right he's safe well he's
not really safe but he is castled so he
needs to break open the center so he can
get some counter play here so so now I
am kind of afraid I don't want to take
here so so I kind of give in to him
which is a big mistake let's see let's
see what the computer says I should do
here I'm afraid
oh great so so they like gyms move g4
and they also like e5 they probably hate
what I play though that's not coming up
obviously so I play Knight takes f7 and
then after rook takes f7 I get scared
check rook takes f7 pawn takes e5 his
rook is in a pin so he's got to get out
of that King to g7 so take take and now
we're in an endgame but I'm a much
better right I got one two three four
five six
pause he's only got five and I got a
rook to a knight so I still like my
chances but I'm not going to checkmate
him though all right so Rick to c1 so
sometimes it's probably bad to
overestimate an opponent's attack all
right thank you all right so now I do
all right but it doesn't have the same
bite because he cannot actually he
decides to B we can go to g7 I get the
pawn came to g8 work the h6 attacks this
pawn came to f7 hope and I repeat Rick
to c6 double up on this pawn Knight to
e6 rook to h7 check and he does not want
to trade rooks so he decides to go back
and now how can I finish off the game
yeah the immortal pawn fork okay pretty
close so ii six check and the game's
over and now i win the championship so
watch out for those porn Forks for sure
all right guys all right
thank you yeah